Democrats prepare for impeachment new
investigations are launched against
President Trump and we check the mailbag
this is the Ben Shapiro show
well we have a lot to get to today we
will get your questions in the mailbag a
little bit later on it has been a
jam-packed week of not very good news
for the White House there is more not
very good news for the White House on
the way unfortunately today we will talk
about all of that but we begin today by
reminding you that it is simply not
responsible for you to rack up the
credit card debt and then never pay it
off or have a plan before doing so which
is why you should consolidate your
credit card debt and get a lower rate
and make sure that you can pay it off so
you're not paying it off until you're
dead with Lending Club you can
consolidate that debt or pay off your
credit cards with one fixed monthly
payment since 2007 Lending Club has
helped millions of people regain control
of their finances with affordable
fixed-rate personal loans no trips to a
bank no high interest credit cards just
go to Lending Club com tell them about
yourself and how much you want to borrow
pick the terms that are right for you if
you're approved your loan is
automatically deposited into your bank
account in as little as a few days
Lending Club is the number one
peer-to-peer lending platform with over
35 billion dollars in loans issued all
you have to do is go to Lending Club
calm /ban check your eight minutes
borrow up to forty grand that's Lending
Club calm slash been again Lending Club
calm slash been all loans made by web
bank member FDIC Equal Housing lender
and if you're racking up those credit
card debts for Christmas and you have no
plans to pay them off remember
the interest rates on those credit cards
can run twenty twenty-five thirty
percent instead of paying that why don't
you consolidate that debt get a loan
make sure you do the responsible thing
check it out Lending Club comm slash
Bend check your eight minutes and borrow
up to forty grand
okay we begin today with Michael Cohen
so Michael Cohen is making the rounds he
is now preparing to go to jail and also
he's preparing presumably to sell a
memoir that he will then write while he
is in jail so when he gets out he has
some sort of revenue coming out it's
amazing to see how the press treat
Michael Cohen versus the way the press
treated for example Linda Tripp way back
when in 1998-1999 so Linda Tripp if
you'll recall was the woman who recorded
phone calls with Monica Lewinsky in
which Lewinsky described being pressured
by the Clinton administration to change
her testimony regarding her affair with
Bill Clinton and then Linda Tripp
revealed these recordings and the press
treated her as just a pariah she was a
rat she was a terrible person how could
you've taped these conversations it was
just just awful well now Michael Cohen
is making the rounds he's on ABC News
exclusively with George Stephanopoulos
the very objective news journalist
George Stephanopoulos once wept
who once said that he and Hillary
Clinton cried and held each other after
the 1992 election and is now an
objective the very objective super
objective News reporter for ABC News
Michael Cohen appears and everybody
still sees Michael Cohen as a sleazy
character but now he's being giving the
royal treatment in the sense that he's
got the goods on president Trump and
therefore must be treated with a certain
baseline level of respect amazing how
that change is based on which party the
president belongs to well Michael Cohen
had some words to say here is some of
what he told at George Stephanopoulos in
this new interview country has never
been more divisive and one of the hopes
that I have out of the punishment that
I've received as well as the cooperation
that I have given I will be remembered
in history as helping to bring this
country back together yeah good luck
with that Michael Cohen I have a serious
problem with the idea that Michael Cohen
the president's fixer who did not
believe any of the polls during 2016
that that guy is gonna bring the country
back together but Democrats seem to be
sort of okay with this idea because
whoever takes down Trump will bring the
country back together I have a new piece
out in Newsweek today talking
specifically about this giant lie that
has been promulgated that president
Trump is the great divider in chief as
though we didn't have divisions before
president Trump every poll shows we were
divided more during the Obama
administration by the end than we were
at the beginning on a variety of
categories including race class and
religion all of that happened under
President Obama that division was the
cause of president Trump's election
Trump is more a result of division than
a cause of division that doesn't mean
that President Trump is a unifying guy I
don't think that he is but to pretend
that President Trump is the sole cause
of our division and that therefore the
curative for that is Michael Cohen
coming in from the wings and spouting
stuff about president Trump it's just
silly and it's the media lying to you by
proxy thousands all Michael Cohen had to
say he also explained that he never had
lied which is weird since he actually
just pled guilty to lines there's that
what do you say to people and you know
there are a lot of people who would be
watching who are gonna be thinking but
wait a second he lied for so long why
she
now what's the answer what do you mean
lied lied about what at the Trump
Organization it's a microcosm of even
just a New York real estate market what
did we lie about it's New York real
estate yes it's the greatest product
ever created is that a lie well I mean
you just sort of pled guilty to the
whole perjury thing so there's that when
people say that you're a liar
maybe it's because you pled guilty in
court to lying and are now going to go
to jail for three years because of it so
probably it's that in any case the
really material part of what Michael
Cohen had to say was in the rest of the
interview he was asked specifically
whether President Trump knew that it was
wrong to pay off stormy Daniels and
Karen McDougal or tried to path Karen
McDougal during the campaign as part of
the campaign and Cohen said of course
according to the New York Times the
comments were mr. cones first since he
was sentenced to three years in prison
by a federal judge on Wednesday he pled
guilty to helping to arrange payments to
the two women a violation of campaign
finance law and for lying to Congress
about the duration of deliberations
about a proposed Trump Tower meeting in
Moscow on Thursday President Trump and
one of his personal attorneys we read
Giuliani said the president was not to
be blamed for the campaign finance
crimes because he trusted Cohen to know
the law Trump tweeted that out yesterday
Trump has lashed out at Cohen on
Thursday President Trump accused Cohen
of trying to embarrass him here is what
President Trump had to say about his
relationship with Michael Cohen he says
he never directed Michael Cohen to do
anything wrong Michael Cohen says that
he lied in order to protect you yeah
what's your response to that let me tell
you I never directed him to do anything
wrong whatever he did he did on his own
he's a lawyer a lawyer who represents a
client is supposed to do the right thing
that's why you pay them a lot of money
etcetera etc he is a lawyer
he represents a client I never directed
him to do anything incorrect or wrong
now this is president from Streif line
of defense so to recap the charges that
are now going to be brought against the
president from probably by the Southern
District of New York there are three
separate charges were really two and a
half that are going to be brought
against President Trump the first is
campaign finance violation the case here
just to recap because I know this stuff
gets complicated so we need to
recapitulate the case here is that
President Trump worked with Cohen and
pushed Cohen to pay off his former
lovers in the midst of an election
after hearing via the National Enquirer
that stormy Daniels was looking to tell
her story the alleged crime here would
be that the Daniels hush money was
supposedly a campaign expenditure given
that the expenditure would not have
existed irrespective of the candidates
election campaign meaning that Trump
wouldn't have paid off stormy Daniels if
it wasn't the middle of an election
cycle so how do we know that Trump would
not have just paid off the annuals
anyway well American media incorporated
the parent company for the National
Enquirer has now admitted that it paid
former Trump paramour Karen McDougal 150
grand in concert with a candidate's
presidential campaign and in order to
ensure that mcdougal did not publicize
damaging allegations about the candidate
before the 2016 presidential election am
i further admitted that it's principal
purpose in making the payment was to
suppress the woman's story so as to
prevent it from influencing the election
Cohen has specifically said that the
payoffs were made at president Trump's
direction president Trump's defense
would be listen I told Michael Cohen
that this thing should go away he's a
lawyer it's his job to do the legal
thing and that's what you're hearing
president Trump expressed on Fox News
right there is that if the law was
broken that's Michael Cohen's fault
that's not my fault
and that's a pretty good case I mean in
order for you to violate campaign
finance law it's one of these weird
areas of law where you have to have
willfully done so meaning that you have
to know that you are actually violating
the law when you violated the law you
can't have done it by accident
negligence the ignorance is sort of a
defense here because you can just send
my lawyer screwed it up and that's
really what Trump is saying here now
that brings us to the second element of
purported criminality and that be the
crime of suborning perjury the crime of
suborning perjury requires a few
elements according to the Department of
Justice one that perjury was committed
to that the defendant procured the
perjury corruptly knowing believing or
having reason to believe it to be false
and that the defendant knew believed or
had reason to believe that the perjurer
had knowledge of the falsity of his or
her testimony so Cohen is already
setting up front for this Cohen is
saying that Trump told him to lie in his
testimony before Congress now all he has
to establish is that Trump instructed
him to lie for him so these are the two
main areas of disagreement between Trump
and Cohen one Cohen is claiming that
trumps hold him to lie Trump is saying I
did not come when does this sort of
thing for a living he's a shady
character I don't have to tell him to
lie he knows exactly where his bread is
buttered but it's not me right me that's
just what he does he goes out and he
lies he says stuff yeah that's Trump's
defense number one Trump's defense
number two on the campaign finance stuff
is I don't know anything about
campaign finance law look at me do I
look like an elections lawyer that's
Michael Cohen's job if he screwed it up
he screwed it up well the problem with
all of this is that President Trump in
his hatred for Michael Cohen then
stepped directly into a pile of dog doo
because in the middle of this Fox News
interview he drops this little doozy
about the kind of work that he had
Michael Cohen doing why did you hire
Michael Cohen first of all that was his
title a very low level work why did you
need public relations than he did law
but he did Safiya to see him on
television he was okay on television but
years ago many years like 12 13 years
ago he did me a favor he was on a
committee and he was so responsive and
so good and I said he's a nice guy okay
so here's the problem if you say that
the lawyer who you say you relied on to
get things done was just doing low-level
work for you mostly PR it is very
difficult to then claim that he was an
expert lawyer you relied on for legal
advice in ensuring that you were
compliant with campaign finance law the
president should not have said this
stuff the president is not his own best
lawyer it turns out that in every
criminal circumstance your lawyer is
your own best lawyer this is why when
you see people representing themselves
on TV in criminal cases every lawyer
says that's stupid hey the key here is
that you should really be quiet now it
also puts president Trump's lawyers in
the difficult position of then having to
figure out what to say next particularly
as new information emerges so according
to NBC News President Trump was the
third person in the room in August 2015
when his lawyer Michael Cohen and the
National Enquirer publisher David pecker
discussed ways pecker could help counter
negative stories about Trump's
relationships with women according to
NBC News this undercuts the case that
Trump normally would make that he would
have spent money no matter what the
election status on stormy Daniels or
Karen McDougal as part of a
non-prosecution agreement disclosed
Wednesday by federal prosecutors
american media inc the Enquirer's parent
company admitted that pecker offered to
help deal with negative stories about
the president and presidential
candidates relationships with women by
among other things assisting the
campaign and identifying such stories so
they could be purchased and their
publication of and their publication
avoided Trump was first identified as
attending the meeting by the Wall Street
Journal so this undercuts Trump's case
that he was ignorant of the campaign
stuff and that it had nothing to do with
the campaign now in a second we're going
to get to how exactly President
from his personal attorney Rudy Giuliani
is dealing with this suffice it to say
that his line of defense is not
particularly good now we will get to
whether any of this is really
prosecutable we'll get to whether any of
this is impeachable we'll get to the
insane number of other investigations
Democrats are leaking which actually
which actually undercuts their message
that they are deeply concerned about the
law and makes it seem more like a
witch-hunt as president Trump has said
way too all of that in just one second
first let's talk about this particular
blazer do you see this blazer look at
this magnificent blazer can this thing
it's lightweight it wears really easily
it's super comfortable it's super soft
and it looks great and not just because
I have the body of a Greek god also
because this jacket is just spectacular
it's comfortable it's stylish it's Peter
Millar my new Peter Miller excursionists
blazer it doesn't just let me dress for
success it means that I addressed for
massive success every day here on this
program Peter Millar has great product
not just the Blazers like this one it
also has great shirts that I wear in my
off hours they have these great khakis
like all their clothes from Peter Millar
are just top of the line it's not every
day you buy a blazer and I'm telling you
this excursion is blazer from Peter
Bhullar will be a great investment for
you head over to Peter maillard comm
/ban check out this blazer some of my
other ptomel our favorites there's a
whole list of stuff that we've got in
there be sure to use my link and you'll
receive free shipping and a
complimentary gift which is awesome
that's Peter Millar mi ll AR dot-com /
Ben that's Peeta Mellark comm slash
spending I have Peter Millar khakis I
peed on my water shoes I Pierre Millar
shirts and it all looks great I mean you
just look like a million bucks and
there's a reason that my wife prefers
when I wear Peeta Mellark go check it
out Peter Malloy calm / Ben mi loa are
calm / Ben when you use that slash Ben
you get a special deal you get to check
out my favorites and also you got free
shipping in a complimentary gets a
pretty solid deal okay so
Rudy Guiliani trying to come back in the
wake of President Trump saying things
and Michael Kohn saying things and
basically everybody gearing up for the
possibility of the Southern District of
New York dropping an indictment on
president Trump for campaign violations
as well as suborning perjury those would
probably be the charges or obstruction
of justice that might be on the table as
well so here's how Rudy Giuliani is
defending President Trump it's not good
it's not a good line of defense so he
says that the campaign finance violation
that Michael Cohen was sentenced for is
quote not a big
crime quote nobody got killed nobody got
robbed this was not a big crime okay
that's not a good legal defense not a
big crime is actually not a standard in
law and we are we are now actually
legally speaking of the fifth avenue
defense remember the president Trump
said during the campaign he could shoot
somebody on Fifth Avenue he wouldn't
lose a single vote
so now apparently the mayor who was
responsible for the implementation of
broken windows theory in New York which
curb crime in New York based on
prosecuting small crimes is now saying
that small crimes don't matter so long
as those small crimes are small enough
and they aren't murder so I guess the
idea is that anything short of murdering
somebody is really not a particularly
big deal now is it true that campaign
finance violations are not enough to
take down a president yes it is true
campaign finance violations are not
enough to take down a president nobody
cares about them everybody assumes the
campaign finance is crap anyway nobody
really thought any differently nobody
thinks the president Trump doesn't pay
off women to keep them silent nobody
thinks the president Trump isn't who
president Trump is see this is the thing
about being president Trump and this is
why and then this will become relevant
in a second when I discuss Democrats
attempts at impeachment which is coming
next then none of this changes your
picture of President Trump I don't know
if there's anyone in the country who
thought the president Trump isn't the
kind of guy who would pay off women he
slept with Mike is there anyone who
thought that is there anybody in the
country who thought that President Trump
was deeply concerned about the
intricacies of campaign violations
campaign finance violations that he was
sitting there going well got to make
sure that nobody spends 2,700 bucks now
to make sure that nobody violates these
particular campaign promises president
Trump has been Donald Trump his entire
life as it turns out and the New York
real estate business is indeed very
dirty as you heard Michael Cohen say
because that doesn't change the image of
who President Trump is it doesn't
actually change how his administration
works and so the idea that he can't
proceed as president of the United
States because of these crimes well
that's just not true and it's obviously
not true and this is the point right
this is where the rubber really meets
the road because the next step here is
going to be Democrats pushing for
impeachment you can already hear them
boxing themselves in Democrats may not
want to push for impeachment Democrats
may want to maintain this controversy up
until the 2020 election but they've
basically forced themselves to move on
because they're now accusing President
Trump openly of criminality which means
the responsibility is on them in the
house to push for impeachment so let's
talk about that a little bit Erichs
wha-whoa is a congressional Democrat and
he says the president Trump presides
over a criminal presidency right this is
the Democrats boxing themselves in to
attempting some sort of impeachment
before the 2020 election you are now
seeing more evidence than ever that
Donald Trump was associated with a
criminal campaign a criminal transition
and presides today very likely over a
criminal presidency and you've seen
people in his orbit who are either under
investigation
have pled guilty or are serving prison
time because of their association with
one or all three of those different
entities well the Democrats keep
screaming criminality they're going to
have to push for impeachment but the
question is could they credibly impeach
President Trump in the House and
Democrats today who are saying well
let's push for impeachment now are these
impeachable crimes so here is my answer
if this had all happened in 1995 the
answer is yes but we live in the post
Clinton era you can separate the the
question of presidential decency and
presidential class in two BC and AC
before Clinton and after Clinton because
before Clinton there was basically a
bipartisan consensus if you committed a
crime you were going to be ousted this
is what happened to Richard Nixon
Republicans supported his impeachment
even though they were members of his own
party that's why he resigned in the
first place but when it came to Bill
Clinton not a single Democrat not one in
the Senate supported his impeachment on
charges that look extraordinarily like
the sort of allegations that are now
being made by President Trump Clinton
was impeached on obstruction and perjury
based on his testimony and pressure on
others regarding their testimony on
Monica Lewinsky and the Senate then
acquitted him the political lesson we
all took from this was that impeachment
was deemed inappropriate in cases where
the president could still operate they
said oh well he's got a 70% approval
rating
he can still be the president these
crimes don't really go to his efficacy
well those same arguments now apply to
President Trump and in fact President
Trump would not have been successful it
would not have been successful in his
presidential primary run if it had not
been for a widespread perception that
morality no longer mattered in politics
a perception that Springs directly from
the Clinton years hey now we're gonna
hear from Democrats that this is
different that it's not truly the same
they're gonna say the campaign
finance thing is different Clinton
didn't violate purposefully campaign
finance law except for the fact that
during his actual campaign in 1996 there
was solid evidence that the Chinese
government was trying to funnel money
into his campaign so there are serious
campaign finance violations with regard
to Clinton it's called China gate at the
time and by the way it's not even clear
as Rudy Giuliani sort of says here it's
not even clear that hush money payments
can even fall under the rubric of
campaign expenditures particularly
because President Trump could have been
spending years paying off all of these
women Clinton suborn perjury he
obstructed justice about ancillary
matters that's really what people are
talking about with regard to President
Trump now the Democrats are gonna say
well Republicans are hypocrites because
Republicans voted for the impeachment of
Clinton in 1998 and 1999 which by the
way is not even completely true a bunch
of Republicans voted against a
conviction in the Senate it was a
Republican Senate that acquitted
President Clinton in 1999 but the hue
and cry by the media is going to be that
Republicans are hypocrites they voted to
impeach Clinton and now they're not
voting to impeach President Trump but
here's the thing the reality on the
ground has now changed once one group of
people violates the rules you have
obliterated the rules our country exists
on an unspoken set of assumptions about
things that we hold in common as we have
seen in virtually every area of American
life we no longer hold very many things
in common one of the things that we
clearly do not hold in common and did
not hold in common was our perspective
of what the presidency should be once
the Democrats violated the rules the
Republicans said listen we are not going
to hamper ourselves by continuing to
apply rules with regard to character and
morality in the presidency when
Democrats are pretty clearly not
interested in any of that sort of stuff
we're not going to be held to account by
Democrats for doing this sort of stuff
now so I think that in an ideal world
Republicans would still uphold that
standard yeah I do but this isn't an
ideal world and the idea that
Republicans are going to unilaterally
disarm in the face of Democrats who now
say oh we want to reconstitute this
standard let's reconstitute the standard
of class in office we all know you're
lying we all know that you are not
telling the truth that if you got rid of
President Trump on suborning perjury and
obstruction of justice after defending
Bill Clinton we don't actually think
that next time a Democrat does this
stuff you are going to support their
impeachment we think that you're only
holding this standard for president
Trump because you're a bunch of partisan
hacks and that being the case we are not
going to help reinstitute a standard for
us
does not apply to you there has to be a
collective mutually assured destruction
that takes place that mutual assured
destruction has not been achieved and
that's why I think Republicans are not
going to move against President Trump
nor do I think that they probably should
politically speaking move against
President Trump most likely scenario
here is he's impeached by a Democratic
House sometime in the next two years and
then he runs for reelection because he's
under threat of indictment by the
Southern District of New York that is
the most likely scenario in all this now
president Trump has complained about
this all this being witch-hunt and
there's some evidence to support him and
I want to talk about that in just a
second but first let's talk about how I
can make and watch look better do you
see this you see this magnificent
timepiece that lies upon the wrist of
yours truly do you see this look how
classy it looks look how nice look how
simple and elegant it is well that is
the style of movement watch's movement
watches they're not designed to tell how
many steps you're taking today or how
many calories you're gonna lose or
anything like that they're designed to
tell you the time in a minimalist
fashion that looks expensive but doesn't
cost you a ton of money movement is a
really amazing success story after their
bunch of ground-up entrepreneurs who
started this thing essentially from a
garage and now they sold two million
watches worldwide and movement watches
are all about looking good without
spending a billion dollars movement
watches start at just 95 bucks they're
looking at 400 bucks for the same
quality from a traditional brand it's
got clean design minimalist really
quality products I've got a movement
with two movement watches actually my
wife has one that I got her for a gift
my mom has one my father has one
everybody in my family has a movement
watch because they really are nice
movements and all the hard work this
holiday season they've made awesome gift
boxes and packages as well if you need
help giving the perfect gift this season
but you don't know where to start the
guys over a movement have your back at
15% off today with free shipping and
free returns by going to MVM t.com slash
Shapiro again that's MVM t-dot-com
slash up hero movements launching new
styles on their site all the time MVM
t.com slash apparel go join the movement
okay so president Trump claims that this
is all a big witch-hunt and to be honest
with you it looks like a little bit of a
witch-hunt when every single aspect of
president Trump's life is being picked
apart we talked about the fact that the
newly elected Attorney General in the
state of New York has already said that
she's gonna go after members of trumps
family she's not even gonna go looking
for crime she's going to look at members
of the
from family for having committed crime
which is the definition of selective
prosecution if you're looking at someone
and you are attempting to dig down on
them just to uncover a crime that
committed as opposed to finding a crime
and then linking it with the actual
perpetrator this is the definition of
bad law enforcement and yet this is what
so many people on the Left are doing the
latest example of this is apparently
according to The Wall Street Journal
federal prosecutors in Manhattan are now
investigating whether president Trump's
2017 inaugural committee misspent some
of the record 107 million dollars it
raised from donations people familiar
with the matter said the criminal probe
by the Manhattan US Attorney's Office
which is in its early stages also is
examining whether some of the
committee's top donors gave money in
exchange for access to the incoming
Trump administration policy concessions
or to influence official administration
positions some of the people said giving
money in exchange for political favors
could run afoul of federal corruption
laws let's be straight about this
President Trump came into office saying
all of Washington DC is corrupt and he
said I myself have engaged in this
corruption I was at Hillary Clinton came
to my wedding I paid the Clintons so
that Hillary Clinton and Bill Clinton
would come to my wedding I would get
politicians in here all the time begging
me begging me to give the money and I'd
say okay what can you do for me
I mean built Donald Trump said this
stuff during the campaign does anyone
really under the impression the weird
misimpression that people who donate to
inaugural committees don't expect
anything in return
are we all under this weirdness
impression that people just decide oh I
like Barack Obama so much I'm gonna dump
a million bucks into his own
inauguration or does it mean that you're
gonna get an ambassadorship to the
Bahamas everybody knows how this game
works but now we're having federal
prosecutors look at the inauguration
committee without presumably any
evidence that anything is happening so
far it's pretty amazing the inaugural
committee hasn't been asked for records
or been contacted by prosecutors
according to a lawyer close to the
matter who said we are not aware of any
evidence the investigation the journal
is reporting actually exists but that's
not stopping apparently the
investigation from moving forward
federal prosecutors have asked rich Rick
gates a former campaign aide who served
as the inaugural committee's deputy
chairman about the fund spending and its
donors according to people familiar with
the matter so basically they're gonna
now dig through every element of Trump's
life in an attempt to get him it does
make it seem a lot like a witch-hunt
when everybody is hunting for witches
now it's possible they
up with some witches in the witch hunt
but that doesn't change the motivating
factors underneath all of this and
that's why if President Trump is
successfully able to convey that all of
this is in fact a big effort to get him
even if he's guilty of some of it then
maybe it doesn't hurt him quite as much
as people think
come 2020 especially when the media
continue to gain give credibility to
just randos who make any allegation
about the president under any
circumstances like Mediaite today has a
big piece about a former staffer on the
apprentice and current stand-up comic
named noel casler who claims that donald
trump was it was a speed freak who
snorted crushed up adderall hey that's
not the most credible sourcing and it's
not the most credible story considering
that Donald Trump is a teetotaler
because his brother was an alcoholic and
apparently has gone around for years
young people and told them not to do
drugs and not to do alcohol nonetheless
this guy who worked on The Apprentice
said that he worked on some of trumps
beauty pageants during the 1990s in
which President Trump would would offer
girls to come up to his hotel room again
unless there's criminal activity alleged
I'm not sure what exactly the revelation
is there but the point is that no matter
what the allegations are against
President Trump substantiated or not
they'll get heavy play from all the
people who want to see him go and it's
Democrats in the House Nancy Pelosi
saying we're gonna go after his tax
returns yesterday if President Trump
could get Democrats somehow to convey
that it doesn't matter they can go after
every aspect of his life and he's the
victim in all of this then he could
successfully run for re-election at
least on the basis that this is a group
of vindictive jerks who are trying to
come after him Nancy Pelosi looking
pretty vindictive right here yes there
is popular demand for the four for the
Congress to request the president's tax
returns they will have their path as we
go forward I'm sure the White House will
resist and so question is how do we go
where do we go from there so now there's
okay and I don't have to hear from from
this person I mean again this idea that
tax returns are also on the table
everything's on and we all know what the
real motivating factor here's joy joy
behar who is sort of the it of the
Democratic brain and she basically
spills it she says listen anybody who
likes from anybody who supports Trump
Trump himself family members they
I'll go to jail it's so funny to hear
all these people who are very angry at
people shouting lock her up about
Hillary Clinton who committed federal
crimes in concealing and and keeping on
private servers classified information
all these same people who are livid
about lock her up are saying lock
everybody up I don't like Joy Behar
conveying the the sort of emotional
emotional bursting forth that Democrats
would really like to see here speaking
against truth to power about job why
does he say she even if he commits a
crime and I think there's more that's
gone on holiday whatever I think favors
have been done and it's got no idea what
a Grammy interestedly okay so the so
Orrin Hatch needs to go to jail because
he's nice to president Trump there are a
lot of folks in this country who are
fans of President Trump and if they get
the feeling that all of this is is a
setup it's gonna be a problem for
Democrats and meanwhile in other Trump
world news the ongoing search for chief
of staff continues apparently two of the
top candidates are Jared Kushner the
president's son-in-law who is
responsible for a vast swath of policy
inside the Trump administration from
criminal justice reform to Middle
Eastern policy has been under a lot of
fire recently for his relationship with
Mohammed bin Salman who is the the de
facto king of Saudi Arabia Kushner of
course is Ivana Trump husband and is
very close with President Trump
personally there's been talk that he
might be up for chief of staff I think
there'll be a very bad move for the
Trump administration Jared already has
an enormous amounts of power over the
policy in the Trump administration now
let me just make a note I'm not for
nepotism
I don't like nepotism I don't like the
idea that you're related to the
president therefore you get a position
in high politics but let's not pretend
that this is unique to President Trump
this isn't what about ISM because again
I don't think it's right that this is
happening on the Republican side of the
aisle but nepotism is a bipartisan
feature Bobby Kennedy became Attorney
General because his brother was
President of the United States at the
time which is an insane thing that was
allowed to happen to have it you're like
I can appoint a family member to be the
person overseeing the Justice Department
that's supposed to oversee me pretty
wild and then Teddy Kennedy ran for
Senate on the back of his brother and
then you have the Clintons obviously and
Hillary Clinton running on the back of
being married to the president then
running for president on the back of
being married to a former president it
turns out that nepotism is a bipartisan
problem in the United States should
I'd be chief of staff no I think
honestly I Trump shouldn't have a chief
of staff if Trump Sherman says duty
wants to do he's going to anyway
Trump's just appoints himself chief of
staff he's just say no and can run this
place like I can I'm my own chief of
staff because that's the reality anyway
when he wanted to ignore John Kelly he
just ignored John Kelly when he wanted
to ignore Reince Priebus he just ignored
Reince Priebus like who cares he should
just appoint himself chief of staff have
any but have a scheduler who's out front
in his office you can bring back the
lady from the Trump Organization make
her the scheduler and then just run the
thing like he wants to run the thing as
a family business the other person who
they are discussing is Chris Christie
which is just beyond insane bringing in
Chris Christie the the corruption ridden
former New Jersey Governor to who most
famously got was sent to go get like
hamburgers for president Trump on the
campaign trail
my President Trump can't find anyone
else in the United States who wants to
go get a member who wants go get him a
Diet Coke in a burger he's got to bring
in Chris Christie just to serially
humiliate him a national television you
remember when Chris Christie became part
of the Trump campaign and every other
Trump rally was Trump pointing over to
Christine going look at the loveable fat
man over here look at him he's so bouncy
and jelly Chris get out of here good get
me go get shinebox Chris and I was like
I guess it'll be entertaining for a
couple of years but how that doesn't
create more turmoil in the executive
branch is beyond me because Christie has
his own priorities he's at odds with a
lot of current members of the
administration it's all a bit of a mess
Trump sure just appoints himself chief
of staff and be done with this damn
thing it's it's very silly okay in a
second I want to get to the worst media
story of the day it really is incredible
a couple of bad media stories actually
but first I want to talk to you about
how you can defend yourself how can you
defend yourself with the best possible
armaments well this is where bravo
company manufacturing comes in bzm was
started in a garage by a marine vet more
than two decades ago to build a
professional-grade product that meets
combat standards I'm a person who owns
guns not because I go hunting I don't
not because I love going target target
shooting it's fine but the reason I own
guns is to protect myself BCM believes
the same thing they believe the same
level of protection should be provided
to every American regardless of whether
they are a private citizen or a
professional BCM is not a sporting arms
company they design engineer and
manufacture life-saving equipment they
assume each rifle leaving their shop
will be
in a life-or-death situation by a
responsible citizen law enforcement
officer or a soldier overseas each
component of a BCM rifle his hand
assembled and tested by Americans to a
life-saving standard VCM feels a moral
responsibility as Americans to provide
tools that will not fail the user when
it's not just a paper target but
somebody coming to do them harm BCM
works with leading instructors of
marksmanship from top levels of
America's Special Ops forces from Marine
Corps Force reconnaissance US Army
Special Ops forces who can teach the
skills necessary to defend yourself your
family or others go check them out right
now at Bravo Company MFG comm they are
fantastic people I've met them they're
great go check them out Bravo Company
MFG comm find out about their product
special offers upcoming news also go
check out their videos at youtube.com
slash Bravo Company USA again that's
youtube.com slash Bravo Company USA
fantastic guys and their product is
really first-rate ok we're gonna get to
a lot more plus the mailbag but first
you're gonna have to go over and
subscribe over at the daily wire now we
have a quick announcement here it's it's
it's pretty exciting stuff coming up in
2019 young America's Foundation starts
up my spring speaking tour and we are
going to be kicking it off at George
Washington University on January 17th so
make sure you have your leftist tiers
tumblers prepared if you don't have time
to get your protests ready for the event
don't fret I'll be all over the east and
west coast check out yeah org for info
on what I'll be at a campus near you I
mean so much goodness we're going to a
bunch of Gonzaga get ready the
administration says I'm not coming well
we will see about that because that's a
thing that's going to happen also go
subscribe right now for a daily wire
when you do you get the rest of the show
live plus two additional hours come
January of this show live it's going to
be awesome and we have all sorts of
special goodies coming up also don't
miss Andrew clavin's next chapter of
another Kingdom performed by the
execrable Michael Knowles today we'll be
live-streaming the first 15 minutes of
episode 10 titled The Last Dragon The
Ballad of Nancy Pelosi we hope you've
enjoyed this season of another Kingdom
head on over to daily wire.com subscribe
to rewatch the full first and second
seasons and receive premium access to
all upcoming content go check that out
right now
and get all that stuff for $9.99 a month
and for $99 a year which is cheaper than
the $9.99 a month you get this the very
greatest in all beverage vessels the
leftist tears hot or cold tumblr look at
it look at it I mean just my goodness
the solidity of it the magic of it its
ability to come
tane liquid I mean this you know how
good this vessel is this vessel is so
good that whatever liquid you pour it
into it actually takes the shape of the
vessel it's unbelievable
you know you won't it's astonishing it's
just an astonishing property of this
particular beverage vessel so go check
that out right now also please subscribe
over YouTube and iTunes we have all
sorts of goodies coming and Sundays
specials the lore all sorts of new
extras that we are creating all the time
and and what was that oh yeah that's
true and we are we are also up for an I
heart radio award this is true as well
so you should go to iHeartRadio comm and
vote for us in the best news category
you can vote up to 5 times just like
you're a Democrat in Chicago circa 1960
so go check that out right now
and leave us a review over to iTunes
that always helps us in the rankings we
are the largest fastest growing
conservative podcast in the nation
[Music]
all right so worth media story of the
day this is this is just media
malfeasance in an extraordinarily high
level so the Washington Post is blasting
out this headline seven-year-old migrant
girl taken into Border Patrol custody
dies of dehydration exhaustion now if I
were to just read that headline I would
think that a seven-year-old girl was
taken into Border Patrol custody and she
was totally fine right there she was
healthy and happy and bouncing off the
walls and then the cruel Border Patrol
agents allowed her to die of dehydration
and exhaustion that of course is not
what happened when you read the article
what you see is that a seven-year-old
girl from Guatemala died of dehydration
in shock after she was taken into Border
Patrol custody last week for crossing
from Mexico into the US illegally with
her father and a large group of migrants
along a remote span of the New Mexico
desert US Customs and Border Protection
said on Thursday according to CBP
reports the girl and her father were
taken into custody about 10:00 p.m.
December 6th south of Lordsburg New
Mexico as part of a group of 163 people
who approached u.s. agents to turn
themselves in more than eight hours
later the child began having seizures at
6:25 a.m. CBP records show emergency
responders who arrived soon after
measure her body temperature 105 point 7
degrees and according to a statement
from CBP she reportedly had not eaten or
consumed water for several days so whose
fault is it that this girl this port
this poor child died of dehydration
probably her father who brought her
along on a thousands mile journey and
didn't feed her or give her water and
the CBP agents who took her into custody
we don't know what they did in the 8
hours between when they got her and when
she started having seizures we don't
even know if they were able to review
her health
there were 163 people who they knew
nothing about they gathered into a place
and then started processing and 8 hours
later the girl was already dying after a
helicopter flight to Providence
Children's Hospital in El Paso the child
went into cardiac arrest and was revived
according to the agency but the child
did not recover and died at the hospital
less than 24 hours after being
transported the father remains in El
Paso awaiting a meeting with Guatemalan
consular officials according to the CBP
the agency is investigating the incident
to ensure appropriate policies were
followed food and water are typically
provided to migrants and Border Patrol
custody and it wasn't immediately clear
Thursday if the girl received provisions
and a medical exam before the onset of
si
because here's one of the things about
dying of dehydration if you don't drink
for set for many days and then you're
given a little bit of water that may not
help you you may in fact need IV it may
not be enough just to give somebody a
little bit of water this idea that if
you give somebody a cup of water if they
haven't had a drink for five days
suddenly they will be they'll be saved
from dehydration it is just not the case
according to spokesman and Romina and
Border Patrol agents took every possible
step to save the child's life under the
most trying of circumstances as fathers
and mothers brothers and sisters we
empathize with the loss of any child
naturally the ACLU blame the CBP for all
of this this is obviously the fault of
the parents if you if you cross a giant
desert without feeding your child and
then you arrive at a place and within
eight hours the kid is having seizures
you're the parent you're the parent the
agency said it was expecting an autopsy
on the child but results would not be
available for several weeks an initial
diagnosis by physicians at Providence
Hospital listed the cause of death as
septic shock fever and dehydration again
dehydration is not just you didn't drink
for 12 hours or he didn't drink for 24
hours it's if you die of dehydration
you've not had a drink for a very long
time and it's quite possible that if you
try to give somebody water after they
are this dehydrated they start throwing
it up anyway so it's just bad media
coverage just stupid bad media coverage
because this is the way the media tried
to push a particular narrative now
speaking of bad media stories I am sad
to see that the Weekly Standard has now
been shut down and the Weekly Standard
has been sort of a an institutional
tentpole in the conservative movement
for some 23 years who shut down by
klarity Media Group the announcement
came after magazines editor Stephen
Hayes met privately with Ryan McKibben
who's the chairman of the weekly
standards published for media DC
McKibbon said in a press release for
more than 20 years the Weekly Standard
has provided a valued and important
perspective on political literary and
cultural issues of the day the magazine
has been home to some of the industry's
most dedicated and talented staff I
thank them for their hard-working
contributions not just to the
publication but the field of journalism
there's a lot of really talented writers
over at the Weekly Standard I hope to
work with some of them in the future and
I'm sad to see them go employees were
told they would be paid through the end
of the year and that afterward they'd
receive severance which would range in
scale to receive severance employees
would need to sign an NDA
however employees were also told to
clear out their desks by the end of the
day and they said their email addresses
were already being in the process of
being shut off which is pretty amazing
the the editor of the Weekly Standard
basically said the reason they're being
shutdown is because they were anti-trump
it's not just that the weekly standard
was anti-trump is that the Weekly
Standard started to reflect the
Preferences of Bill Kristol
who seems to have lost his mind a little
bit over president Trump Bill Kristol
who I have respected as a thinker for a
very long time yeah the fact that he
decided to tell people to vote for I
believe he told people to vote for
Democrats in the last election cycle and
that he's sort of taken the max boot
position on Trump which is anything
Trump does is bad that's not likely to
win you a lot of friends and admirers or
readers and that's too bad because
there's so many talented writers over
there I'm sure they will all get jobs
and I will work to help them get jobs at
other outlets because again I don't like
to see talented people go without work
okay so time for a little bit of Mel but
let's just a mailbag today
okay so Stephen says if justice Ginsberg
we're to die before the midterm election
it basically the same chronological time
as Justice Scalia did should the
Republicans proceed with confirming a
new justice before the election or not
the answer is of course Republicans
should proceed with confirming a new
justice they should not wait until after
the presidential election the actual
rationale for not voting on Merrick
garland was not that it was the middle
of a presidential cycle the actual
rationale for not voting on Merrick
garland is because Merrick garland did
not have the votes in the Senate to be
approved end of story
it was always in my opinion a very
stupid maneuver to suggest that Merrick
garland should get a vote if Hillary
Clinton had been elected like I don't
think it's the responsibility of the
Senate to green-light any judge it does
not want to green-light that's the way
that our constitutional system works
Michael says hey Ben I have two
questions I think only you might have
the answer is question one is it true
you said Michael Mol's is an essential
employee question two could it ever be
possible that he could be one day thanks
Michael well Michael I like that Michael
wrote a letter about himself to us
that's exciting
no I did not say knowles was an
essential employee i said every employee
of the daily will of the daily wire was
an essential employee but every rule has
its exceptions and Michael I like to
think of more as an independent
contractor to be frank and second could
it ever be possible that he could be an
essential employee one day well yeah I
mean we could put him to work scrubbing
toilets or something that would make
more essential than he is now Carlos's
Haven how do you reconcile evolution
with the Bible more specifically Genesis
1:27 God created mankind in our image
and likeness is that consistent with the
idea that we come from monkeys yes it is
because the question is what does it
mean to be created in God's image or
likeness in my opinion and in the view
of a lot of biblical commentators what
this actually means that you are created
with an independent creative capacity
that does not belong to animals you have
the ability to transform the world to
make independent free wills choices and
that is being made in the image of God
it's not that God looks like a human and
something God that has two nostrils and
two hands and two feet right that's
that's not what it means when it says
God created mankind their image and the
general view of natural law scholars
ranging from Thomas Aquinas to
Maimonides is that God can use whatever
natural process as he wishes in order to
for him to accomplish his goals and so
when the Bible describes the creation of
the universe then that could very easily
in sort of scientific parlance be
described as the natural processes of
the universe the question is what stood
behind that process what made that
process happen the way that process was
made to happen Oprah says hello Ben
now that we know Michael avenatti isn't
going to run in 2020 while you and Joe
endorse Jim Acosta for president no Jim
Acosta in his own mind is already
president I don't want to disabuse him
of that Kevin says Kevin Kevin why why
did you want to be a lawyer and why did
you stop so okay I have a lot of great
stories about my law firm interview
process so I had them as far as I know
the most unsuccessful I'm off from
interview process for anyone who
graduated laude from Harvard Law
School maybe in their history so the way
that works at Harvard Law School is that
when you graduate or when you're getting
ready to graduate all these law firms
come and they recruit you because you're
a Harvard Law graduate which means
you're special so they all come to the
Charles hotel and they roll out the red
carpet and you interview them basically
they interview you and you also
interview them to see what sort of firm
that you'd like to work for
so I registered for some 32 interviews I
got one offer out of 32 now this was not
because of my grades right this was
because specifically on my resume I had
a bunch of my books and my books
included titles like brainwashed how
universities indoctrinate America's
youth and porn generation how social
liberalism is destroying our future
right titles like that are not apt to
when you admirers in legal circles where
everybody is a far leftist and so I
would have interview experiences where I
remember
walked into one interview with a major
law firm called Gibson Dunn and Crutcher
which has outlets all over the country I
believe this was the Orange County
branch maybe in any case I walk into the
interview before I can even sit down the
guy doesn't even shake my head doesn't
even say hello I walk into the room
before I can sit down the partner behind
the desk says it's always been my
contention that conservatives and
religious people in general have a
freudian of fear of sex and I looked at
him I thought well I'm not getting this
job so I said that is the stupidest
effing thing I have ever heard in my
entire life my prediction came true I
did not get that job but there are a lot
of experiences that were just like that
I mean I interviewed one time at
Kirkland Ellis another first-rate law
firm a lot of friends who work for
critical in Dallas and they called me
back for a call back in Los Angeles and
they decided when they do these call
backs they're trying to recruit you and
so what they do is they put you with
people they think you will get along
with people who will talk about how
great the firm is so they decide you
know it'd be great we'll put Shapiro
with a couple of other Jewish Harvard
Law graduates this is pretty much the
worst thing you can do because if you
are a Jewish person who is not Orthodox
chances are that you're extraordinarily
liberal and as it turns out that's
exactly right one of these people was a
radical environmentalist and another of
them was a feminist lawyer so we're all
out too and then they say okay well
let's all go to lunch together and I
said well I can go I'm just not gonna
eat anything right I'll have like a Coke
and you guys can eat it'll be fine I do
it all the time no no no we need to go
to a kosher restaurant the only kosher
restaurant in downtown LA at the time
was a greasy falafel shop so there we
are in our expensive suits at a greasy
falafel shop challenge a non falafel and
one and the girl who and the girl the
woman happens to be a lesbian and the
guy who's sitting next to her we're all
talking he reaches into his pocket and
he pulls out an old column that I've
written because I've had a syndicated
column by this point but at this point
for like six years
he pulls out a column that I've written
he starts reading to me from my own
column and then he says and then he says
do you agree with this I said well yeah
I wrote it and it was a calm about
same-sex marriage and the woman says
well I'm a lesbian and I said in my
typical fashion so and she was very
upset about this because she assumed
that I guess because she was a lesbian I
would now change my entire worldview on
same-sex marriage
because this is how the left thinks it's
a personal insult to members of the left
if you don't change your entire
worldview based on their personal life
experiences which is pretty a shocking
thing in any case those interviews went
poorly the one that one the worst though
and this is me getting to the answer the
one that went the worst was I was
specifically asked by at one point by
one of these firms why I wanted to work
in corporate law why I wanted to be a
corporate attorney and I looked at the
interview and I said for the money which
is the obvious and honest answer to
anyone who wants to practice corporate
law right you're not you're not going to
corporate law for the love of the law
and anybody who says they are is a liar
okay the reason you're going there is
cuz the partners are making a couple
million bucks here the notion that you
are going from Harvard Law School where
you study how to be Atticus Finch and
you say about legal theory and you study
about originalism versus legal realism
and it's all about ideas and then you go
to a law firm where you sit in a room
and you review page numbers and commas
and missing paragraph indents for 2,200
billable hours a year the idea that you
are doing this for the pure enjoyment of
Blackstone's commentaries is insane so
anyway he said why are you doing this I
said for the money so that's my same
answer to you why would why did I want
to be a lawyer for the money I mean
right now I finished I won said I went
to college I got my degree in Poli Sci
you can't get a great job with Poli Sci
my mom had always been sort of
practicing kind of law she was in
business affairs so you should get your
law degree like I'm not really sure I
want to took the LSAT I did really well
I got into Harvard she's like now you
have to go I said okay fine and then
after that I was like what do you do now
while you work in law so that was the
idea also I wanted to learn the real
estate business that is something that
did not end up happening okay Samuel
says hey Ben what do you find when do
you find time in your busy schedule for
writing your novels do you set aside a
specific timing today or do you set
aside a specific time entirely to
working on a novel I've been listening
for a couple of years now and greatly
appreciate the balanced approach and
your honesty Thank You Samuel so um I
worked on my novel truly Jen's sort of
in my spare time I do have to carve out
times in the day and what I've realized
is that I have to tell I have to tell my
assistants those around me that they
need to not scheduled my day that I need
a block of like three hours if I
actually want to get anything done I
need blocks of two or three hours and
when somebody says to you can I have
five minutes of your time the answer
should usually be no because five
minutes and
my time is not five minutes my time it's
the 15 minutes in preparation for the
five minutes of my time and then the 15
minutes after we're getting back into my
work there is no such thing as a five in
a block of your time even a person
asking you a question
for 30 seconds requires you to be
wrenched out of your work and then it
takes to another 10 minutes to get back
into your works you really do need to
have undivided blocks of time where you
simply are not bothered if you want to
write that's true whether you're writing
nonfiction or fiction obviously I read a
lot more nonfiction than fiction Terry
says hey Ben I've been living in
California since the military stationed
me here six years ago at first I love
the state cuz I was young and so I
myself is more of a liberal but as I
grew older and more educated I
definitely find myself firmly on the
conservative side of the fence I
recently decided I want to move away
from California to find a state with
lower taxes and more job opportunities
you have any recommendations for cities
that are potentially worth moving to
thanks for the awesome content well
there are a lot of fantastic cities in
states that are more conservative you
know in terms of just pure beauty of the
city Charleston South Carolina is a
gorgeous City I think it's the prettiest
city that I've ever been to it's just
beautiful but in terms of great cities
that are in conservative areas obviously
Dallas is a fantastic City I like
Oklahoma City I'll be honest today I
think Oklahoma City is great I think
Nashville is great talent there there
are a lot of really great towns that I
have been to in conservative states and
honestly where I not wedded to being
near a Jewish community that would give
me a lot more options on where to live
okay one more question
let's see Cory says my economics teacher
tried to argue that America's monotheism
and capitalism have failed and we should
adopt some Chinese policy
what would your argument to this be
thank you Cory centralized planning
works in the short run in the sense that
it directs capital toward a particular
goal and that goal can be successful in
the short run it does not work in the
long run because the bottom line is that
the collective wisdom of the crowd when
it comes to the products and services to
be created much stronger much more
versatile much more durable than
anything direct to top down it is
amazing to watch as people make the same
economic errors over and over back in
the 1920s and 1930s there were a lot of
folks in the West who said wow look at
the growth rates in Stalin's Russia look
at that the five-year plans and then all
of that collapsed right and turns out
that all of that was fake when you keep
your people in a stat in in a state of
abject misery for 30 years and then give
them gradual gains and turns out they're
happier because of the gradual games
math does not
the people in China are living a
lifestyle anything comparable to the
lifestyle of the United States the
United States is still the world driver
of the economy if the United States
economy were to go into recession the
entire world that goes into recession
the same thing is not necessarily true
of the Chinese economy which has
experienced several serious economic
shocks in the past several years and
that has had some impact but certainly
not tremendous global impact in the same
way that the United States economy has
it's just monotheism and capitalism
haven't worked have you seen a chart of
GDP per capita since the advent of free
markets in the early 19th century
it looks exponential this is just the
stupidest crap I've ever heard really
that's so dumb like read a book a book
okay um let's see okay we'll do some
things there's so many good questions
today I'm sad we can't get to all of
them but let's get to some things I like
and then some things that I hate so
things I like last night we had our
Christmas party over at my business
partner Jeremy borings house the
god-king Jeremy boring and it was
beautiful I mean it's really well
decorated and really nice and my and and
a bunch of the the folks who work at the
company we're all singing holiday songs
like like Wonderwall together I was very
weird everybody and and here's the thing
about the daily wire staff it was a dry
party and everybody was still singing
there like they were drunk together the
the estimable Balthus Glover did a
rather fantastic rendition of call me
maybe' with acoustic piano which as it
turns out call me maybe not a good song
and call me maybe without any production
value particularly not good but math has
got very into it
Sonya's rendition of can't help falling
in love with you was was definitely a
classic of the genre
we had Nick who is out there singing
with the full passion that he could
bring to it we had Alex and and Dylan
and they the twins with the beards and
they were they were singing every rock
song that cutting us that was a lot of
fun when we when we walked in when
everybody walked in I got to the party a
little bit early and part of the joke
was that I was going to pull out the
violin as though I was playing a set
with the pianist and so one of the
things that we played was actual good
music by Bach this would be Jesu joy of
man's desiring which by the way is
or Christmassy it turns out then
Wonderwall who would have thought or the
entire crowd singing Bohemian Rhapsody
on Christmas which is a weird call in
any case here is a little bit of Jesu
joy of man's desiring some the most
beautiful music ever composed by an
actually talented human
[Music]
okay so it's great music okay time for
in the wake of that time for some stuff
I hate okay so things I hate this one
goes out to my wife
so last night last night it's like 10:30
p.m. and it's time to go to sleep but I
need to go to the kitchen for something
and our hat in our house our bedrooms on
one side of the house um our kitchens on
the other side of the house and in
between I is kind of the den area where
the kids like to play and there is and
so usually we clear a path
you know like good human beings would we
usually clear a path from one to the
other so that if we have to walk in the
dark we don't kill ourselves this had
not been done that's not my wife's fault
that's my kid's fault anyway they
decided to leave out their little chairs
and their little toys so I'm walking
blithely alone happily walking along to
get a bottle of water from the kitchen
and boom I bruised the living hell out
of my shin and I go flying head over
heels over this chair like Dick Van Dyke
over the Ottoman in the original Dick
Van Dyke Show I mean I just go flying
and I clocked the living hell out of my
leg I mean I just destroy my knee I
destroy my shin and and fall directly
from the chair onto my son's Digger he
has like a my son has like you know like
a digger that you would see at a
construction site he has one that you
actually sit on and so I fall from one
object onto another object and then onto
a third object so it was it was great
physical comedy in the dark so I'm lying
on the floor and my wife is in the
bedroom and all she can hear is oh right
she just hears me just shout right just
a blue streak in the middle of the night
and I hear her from the other room are
you okay and I'm like number one no
right you just heard me shout a bunch of
curse words after hearing a giant
clatter of me going down on the floor no
probably not probably not okay
and then my wife comes rushing in and
she sees me on the floor clutching my
leg and I just I mean this thing hurt
like hell I mean it wasn't just like a
shin hurt it was like it was bleeding in
peripheral blood and like my steps
directly on a bunch of blocks the same
time he knows it's ridiculous and I'm
lying
on the floor and my wife is laughing as
hard as I have ever seen her laughs in
her life she is dying I mean she is
crying she is laughing so hard and she's
like honey are you okay she said while
laughing through her tears and and I'm
like no I'm not okay can you get me
you know like an ice pack because I
can't move for a second and she's she's
she's like I'm so sorry that happened
laughing at me the entire time like
literally laughing hey I'm so sorry that
happen and this continues for a solid I
kid you not 15 minutes of her laughing
as I hobble around the house as though
I've been wounded in some sort of
crucial battle and and finally things
calm down and I put an ice pack on my
leg and as we're about to fall asleep
I hear her giggling and laughing because
my wife loves it when I get hurt it is
her favorite thing and I don't know if
this is a I'll have to talk to some more
of the women in the office I don't know
if there's a woman thing because my mom
has the same thing with my father like
it might add clocks himself
my mom thinks it's the funniest thing
that she's ever seen and you know if I
were really really hurt like deeply hurt
like Hospital hurt then I assumed that
my wife would not be quite as pleased
with the situation but when I clocked
myself and it really hurts but I'm not
dying my wife thinks it's the funniest
thing that has ever happened so things I
hate this one goes out to you sweetheart
I love you even if you don't love me and
that's the I guess that's that's the way
the cookie crumbles so solid stuff there
okay final thing that I hate as we
approach Christmas we now get the the
wisdom of a bunch of people who have no
relationship with religion or
traditional judeo-christian values about
whether particular Christian figures
like the Pope are homophobic so Jenny
Hagel who is a writer for Seth Meyers I
guess did an entire monologue the other
night about how Pope Francis is a
homophobe because Pope Francis believes
that homosexuality is a sin which has
been part of judeo-christian canon for
approximately 3,000 years but here is
Jenny Hagel finally explaining the real
reason this has all been done is because
the Pope Pope Francis is a brutal
homophobe press dubbed him cool Pope but
here's the thing this guy's not cool
this guy is homophobic
if you're not Catholic you're probably
thinking why should I care about this
and if you are Catholic you're probably
thinking what's the latest I can leave
my house and still get to Mass on time
but we should all care about this
because the Pope is a world leader who's
giving people permission to be
prejudiced
hey so much humouring from the humorous
what I love is people who are
politically driven and comedians who
have an agenda not being funny at all
and just calling the Pope a homophobe on
the basis they disagree about the status
of particular behavior and whether it is
in fact a sin or not she's gonna have to
name me the policies that the Pope has
pushed that are that are in favor of
cracking down on gay people and
victimizing gay people in fact most of
the Pope's statements on this have been
very soft but this is not enough now we
have to in in the great battle between
secularism in religion second what is it
must emerge victorious and label
everyone who disagrees in evil human
being so well done Seth Meyers and and
his writers okay well we will be back
here on Monday with all of latest one
more week until we go on Christmas break
and then there will be a whole new year
of fun but we are not quite to the end
of the year yet so get ready buckle up
because next week I have a feeling it's
gonna be a crazy one just like every
other week I'm Ben Shapiro this is the
Ben Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Senya Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer is Mathis
Glover and our technical producer is
Austin Stevens edited by Alex and Garo
audio is mixed by Mike Carmina hair and
makeup is by Jess wah of era the Ben
Shapiro show is a daily wire for word
publishing production copyright Ford
publishing 2018